un câlin ces trois fois rien et ça fait
du bien
la télé est blé tendre étreinte alors à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
du canin voici une petite sélection
ils sont petits alors pour commencer le
câlin humoristique
nous sommes en 1983 dans l'émission
merci bernard chaque semaine les
comédiens offrent un cadeau aux
téléspectateurs et ce jour là c'est un
câlin malgré la barrière de l'écran
approchez-vous ça y est vous êtes bien
collé contre la vitre de votre
téléviseur ok on va faire un bon câlins
c'était bon point pour ça c'est pas
grave
un petit chiffon humide et voilà c'est
cadeau tout aussi étonnant mais beaucoup
plus sérieux voici le câlin de silves
aux thérapies il consiste à enlacer des
arbres à la manoeuvre
jacqueline en normandie en 1988
toute la ligne des chars à tout le corps
qui parle du faux jusqu'à l'os du bois
du corps comme ça et après je me sens un
certain moment et après je me sens bien
rechargées il ya une communion qui se
fait avec la allons plus loin avec le
câlin mystique
voici amas de son nom complet mata
amritanandamayi 7 gourou indien est
adulé des stars elle a été invitée aux
nations unies par le pape françois aussi
partout où elle passe
elle attire les foules son pouvoir
donner des étreintes d'un amour infini
démonstration pour 2006 à toulaud tout
comme c'est naturel pour la rivière de
couler c'est naturel pour moi de donner
la main
quand je vois les gens sortir je le
ressens et je suis leurs larmes sur mon
épouse pour les consommables
déroutant peut-être mais le canada a des
vertus médicales c'est céline rivière
qui nous l'expliquent en 2015 d'après
sept psychologues diplômés en thérapie
neuro émotionnelle une étreinte libère
de l'ocytocine et l'ocytocine c est une
hormone qui est extraordinaire puisque
ça permet de libérer beaucoup de
bien-être de la confiance en soi et
c'est exactement à l'opposé des hormones
du stress
aujourd'hui le câlin se fait plus rare
restreint à l'intimité de nos foyers
mais peut-être pour un nom à nouveau
ouvrir nos bras même à des inconnus dans
la rue peut-être bientôt le retour des
free hugs les câlins gratuits des
intéressés
[Musique]